[Musique]
Edou Planel, bonsoir.
Et ben bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Ouais.
Est-ce que
la chaîne qui monte ?
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Euh, j'ai 66 ans, je suis journaliste
depuis plus de 43 ans et depuis 11 ans,
je suis cfondateur et présidente d'un
journal en ligne indépendant,
participatif. qui s'appelle Méia Part.
Euh, on a intitulé
notre vidéo Méia Part, Penala, Macron,
le journalisme en danger. Euh, vous êtes
exposé à d'énormes pression parce que
vous vous soulevez des dossiers piquants
et vous faites un travail de fond, un
travail de moine bénédictin. Ça prend
quelle forme à part quelques petites
perquisitions ? Est-ce que vous êtes sur
écoute ? Est-ce que vous avez des gens
qui vous suivent ? Est-ce que vous avez
établi ? On va on va on continue sur ce
sujet, je vous laisse répondre.
Ouais, je vais je vais raconter sur
l'artisanat, mais avant je voudrais dire
c'est pas nous,
c'est vous.
C'est un droit fondamental qu'ils sont
en train de combattre et de remettre en
cause. Le droit de savoir, c'est
beaucoup plus important que le droit de
vote. Et je dis ça juste avant des
élections dimanche prochain. Si vous ne
savez pas tout ce qui est d'intérêt
public, tout ce qui est fait en votre
nom, tout ce qui est fait avec l'argent
de vos impôts, tout ce qui est fait sans
vous demander votre avis des guerres,
des affaires, de la corruption et plein
d'autres choses, vous allez voter comme
un aveugle et du coup vous allez voter
pour votre pire ennemi ou pour votre
pire malheur. C'est ce qui se passe
autour de nous. C'est ce qui se passe
avec Bolzonaro au Brésil, avec Trump,
avec Erdogan et plein d'autres voir ici.
Et c'est bien ce qui se passe. Nous
avons un pouvoir qui, contrairement à sa
promesse électorale d'il y a 2 ans,
tourne le dos à la société.
Il tourne le dos à la dynamique de la
société. Il ne veut pas l'entendre, il
ne veut pas l'écouter. Il est enfermé
dans sa bulle présidentielle. Et du
coup, lui aussi suit un cours
autoritaire. Et quand on commence un
cours autoritaire, les premiers
adversaires, ce sont pas les opposants
politiques, ce sont les journalistes. Et
d'abord ces journalistes libres et
indépendants qu'on ne peut pas
contrôler. Prenons la séquence récente.
Qui sont les personnes qui font prendre
conscience au pays et y compris au
médias installés dominant
le scandale des violences policières
pendant le mouvement des gilets jaunes ?
de violence illégitimes qui n'ont rien à
voir avec le maintien de l'ordre. Les
œils éborniers, les mâchoires fracturés,
les mains arrachées et bien d'autres
choses. Qui David Dufren qui était au
début de l'aventure de Mediaapart, un
journaliste indépendant, il le fait sur
les réseaux sociaux. médiia part soutien
et le relais et fait toute cette mise en
scène, il y a une base de données que
vous pouvez voir qui vous explique tout
ça. Et c'est bien pour ça qu'ils n'ont
pas aimé le travail des journalistes.
C'est pour ça qu'ils ont commencé à
frapper des journalistes dans les
manifestations. C'est pour ça à leur
envoyer du LBD et à interpeller Gaspar
Glandz qui était de cette jeune
génération hein de cascou mais au sens
aller au plus près hein. C'est ça le
journalisme. aller au plus près pour
voir l'événement.
Journalisme de combat,
journalisme d'engagement au service de
ce droit fondamental. Notre armée est
pacifique, c'est l'information. Alors,
on pourrait continuer Benala évidemment
Méiapartena,
un procureur nommé à la main du pouvoir
et tentative de perquisition à
Médiapartement illégitime continue
par Ri
ce procureur. Il y avait vous savez il y
a le parquet n'est pas indépendant en
France. il est sous la main du pouvoir
exécutif, ce qui n'est pas le cas en
Italie, ce qui n'est pas le cas en
Espagne ou au Portugal he pour prendre
juste d'autres pays du sud de l'Europe.
Et trois noms avaient été proposés pour
être procureur de Paris dans le cadre du
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature. Le
roi, parce que c'est une sorte de
monarque élu, le roi Macron a rayé les
trois noms et a pris celui qui l'a rangé
qui est monsieur Edz qui ne peut rien
lui refuser. D'où cette tentative de
perquisition à médiapinte qui a certes
échoué mais qui avait un but. Montrer
que nous n'étons pas inviolables, faire
peur à nos sources et d'ailleurs la
suite le confirme, c'est la cascade de
convocation à la DGSI, les services
secrets intérieurs. Ça m'était arrivé
déjà moi il y a 2 ans dans le cadre de
révélation d'un document confidentiel
défense sur ce qu'on cachait par rapport
à notre soutien au régime autoritaire
tadien. toujours des vérités légitimes.
Et là pareillement et bien nos amis
c'était sur Media part de disclaose qui
montrent le mensonge. Oui, nous vendons
des armes à l'Arabie Saoudite et aux
Émirats Arabes unis qui servent à quoi ?
À une sale guerre au Yémen où il y a de
la famine et où les premières victimes
sont les populations civiles. Le
pouvoirement, nous montrons ce pouvoir.
Résultat, on est convoqué à la DGSI.
Continuons. C'est ce qui se passe avec
le monde dans l'affaire Benala à
nouveau. Et il faut bien voir ce que ça
veut dire. En démocratie, il y a une loi
qui protège la liberté de la presse. La
formule de la porte-parole du
gouvernement disant "Les journalistes
sont pas au-dessus des lois est une
formule indigne. Car bien sûr qu'ils ne
sont pas au-dessus des lois mais leur
travail leur travail est protégé parce
qu'il est au cœur d'un droit
fondamental. C'est pas n'importe quel
travail. Il est au cœur d'une liberté
fondamentale et qui doit pouvoir surgir
indépendamment de ce que veut le
pouvoir, qui doit pouvoir déranger le
pouvoir, le bousculer, permettre qu'on
l'interpelle. Donc nous nous sommes
prêts toujours à rendre compte de notre
travail mais dans le cadre de cette loi,
la loi de 1880, une loi républicaine
formidable dont la jurisprudence a
permis de construire le côté
démocratique, c'est quoi ? Bien, on
vient, on dit légitimité du but
poursuivi, c'était d'intérêt général. Et
du coup, oui, ça vient du secret
défense, oui, ça vient du secret des
affaires. Oui, ça vient du secret
d'enquête. Oui, mais regardez,
rappelez-nous l'affaire un peu.
Toutes les affaires, toutes les
affaires. Quand vous publiez un dossier
secret défense qui vient du secret
défense, vous montrez que ce secret
défense ne protège pas les intérêts de
l'armée, ne protège pas la vie des
soldats, ne protège pas un secret
militaire indispensable, mais il protège
autre chose. Des armes vendues à des
dictatures, des manœuvres indignes et
illégitimes. Je pourrais vous montrer
l'affaire banc en cours. L'affaire banc
en cours. Bah oui, le majord d'homme
c'était un dictaphone, c'était pas un
téléphone. Le majord d'homme pour
protéger sa patronne qui était victime
d'aigref de la haute société qui voulait
s'approprier sa fortune en abusant de sa
faiblesse, il se dit "Moi, je suis en
servitude." C'était sa formule hein,
ancien régime he on se croirait sous la
royauté. Donc personne va me croire.
Et si personne va me croire, il faut que
j'ai des preuves. Donc je mets ce petit
dictaphone sur la petit la
là où était servi le thé pendant que que
cette dame avait ses conversations
d'affaires. Il fait en sorte que ce soit
entre les mains de la police. Médiapart
obtient ses 21 heures. Nous nous mettons
de côté tout ce qui concerne la vie
privée et nous révélons ce que ça
révèle. de l'évasion fiscale, des
pressions sur la justice, l'abus de
faiblesse sur cette dame, des manœuvres
capitalistiques secrètes et tout ça tout
ça était légitime. On essaie de nous
poursuivre en disant vous êtes complice
d'une atteinte à la vie privée. C'était
un secret. Vous avez pris ça dans un
endroit secret et le majord d'homme est
votre complice ou vous êtes le complice
du majord d'homme. Vous connaissez la
suite au bout de plein d'années, c'était
en 2010 donc c'est tombé finalement
l'année dernière. Nous avons été
relaxés. Évidemment, tout ça était
d'intérêt public et donc c'est toujours
la même question d'intérêt public. Il
n'y a pas de secret absolu, hein. C'est
l'intérêt public et le juge en est
l'arbitre. Et donc notre travail se
passe toujours comme ça. Je pourrais
vous donner un autre exemple. Regardez
l'affaire libyenne, ce grand feuilleton
de médiapart qui montre quand même la
corruption d'une République.
On a reçu à Fabrice Sarfi.
Bah oui. Qui vous a raconté la campagne
de SarkoZi en 2007. Sarkozi pareil, il
contourne cette loi, il nous poursuit
comme si on était des faussères, faux et
usage de faux. Notre document n'était
pas faux, ni un faux matériel, ni un
faux intellectuel. Des années de
bataille pour prouver cela et gagner.
Procédure bayon.
Oui, procédure billon, mais surtout
contourner la liberté parce que s'il
nous avait poursuivi à la loyale, il
aurait encore plus perdu parce que
toutes les preuves auraient été sur la
table. Alors, qu'est-ce que je veux dire
? Je veux dire que là, il y a dans le
pouvoir français actuel qui de ce point
de vue n'est ni libéral ni progressiste,
qui n'est même pas européen parce que
c'est la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme qui souvent nous rappelle à la
loi et nous rappelle aux lois
fondamentales.
Nous la France
et nous la France, nous ce pays. Voilà
hein, je rappelle j'ai la fait une
affaire dont j'ai été victime mais qui
est au cœur d'une question qui est les
écoutes téléphoniques sous la présidence
de Mitteran. Mais les lois qui existent
sur les écoutes téléphoniques en France,
elles ont été imposées par l'Europe.
Donc cette dérive autoritaire n'est pas
n'est pas conforme au blab blabla de la
campagne électorale européenne. Regardez
comme l'Europe et cetera et tout. Ben,
ils sont fait ils sont dans un cours
inverse qui n'est pas loin du cours de
Salvini, d'Orbane. Ils se méfient de la
société et la méfiance de la société
passe d'abord par la méfiance de la
presse libre et indépendante, celle
qu'on ne peut pas contrôler, celle qui
n'est pas aux mains des oligarques,
celle à qui on peut pas donner un petit
coup de fil, avec laquelle on peut pas
faire de com et tout. Donc, je voudrais
souligner ce paysage français, mais le
rapporter à un paysage mondial. Nous
parlons aujourd'hui, hier, qu'est-ce que
nous avons appris ? 17 charges
d'espionnage contre Julian Assange aux
États-Unis sur une loi de 1917
qui a été faite en 1917.
Espion acte.
Mais l'espionne acte, il est pas fait
pour les espions, il est fait pour des
adversaires politiques qualifiés
d'espion. Les communistes, en
l'occurrence, c'était la révolution
russe. Les socialistes, les anarchistes,
toutes les dissidences.
Et jamais depuis que cette loi a été
promulguée au pays du First Amendment,
le premier amendement de la Constitution
américaine, aucune loi ne sera faite
contre la liberté de la presse parce que
c'est un droit fondamental aussi
important que le droit de se réunir, le
droit de manifester, le droit de penser
librement. C'est ça le libéralisme
politique au cœur de la démocratie. Et
donc c'est la première fois que cette
loi est utilisée contre un éditeur de
presse d'information. On peut trouver
que Assange a déconné qu'il était trop
pris dans son personnel, mais par
ailleurs hein, qui vivrait sa vie,
l'isolement qu'il a subi et cetera hein.
Moi, je je ne suis pas juge. On peut
avoir des avis divers là-dessus. On peut
se dire qu'il a peut-être déconné avec
les filles et que la poursuite suédoise
a de bonnes raisons d'être. Ça c'est
autre chose. Il reste que le sort que
lui font les États-Unis d'Amérique n'a
rien à voir avec tout ça.
Ils veulent en faire un exemple
mais il nous concerne tous comme ils ont
fait un exemple de Chelsea Manning qui
est retourné en prison parce qu'elle n'a
pas accepté de témoigner contre Assange
Chelsea Manning grâce à laquelle on a
connu l'ensemble des câbles qui ont
montré le mensonge de la puissance
américaine pendant toute la guerre
d'Irak, l'hypocrisie de sa diplomatie.
le rappelez-vous la vidéo collatéral
murder la saloperie en clair de tuer en
blaguant des civils en l'occurrence
d'eux journaliste
caméraman de reters de reters iraakiens
mais de reters tiré comme au pigeon et
les mecs il blaguent dans leur hélico
pendant ce temps-là donc tout ça c'est
ce sont des ces personnes-là Edward
Snowden, Chelsea Manning Julian Assange
quel que soit leur solitude leur mais ce
sont des héros de ce droit de savoir,
héros malheureux, héros vaincus. Ils ont
commencé, ils avaient pas 30 ans, elle
avait 21 22 ans Chelsea Manning quand
Edward Snowden se s'organise et il
l'organise très bien lui tout seul pour
avoir tous les documents de la National
Security Agency pour montrer
l'espionnage global pour montrer comment
tout ce qu'on utilise est utilisé pour
nous sur chez Hur salvateur dans le sens
avant où disait que tout le monde était
surveillé, on nous traitait de
complotiste, on nous trait et en fait on
avait raison et quand il a sorti bah
un les salaires des à cœur augmenté
et les États ont commencé à se dire
qu'est-ce qui nous arrive parce que le
prétexte est la sécurité, le prétexte
est l'ennemi intérieur mais il sert à
surveiller tout le monde et y compris,
on l'a vu avec les révélations de
Snowden, à surveiller d'abord ses
alliés, ses concurrents économiques, à
espionner même Merkel et Hollande et
cetera. L'Europe,
c'est une honte. Elle aurait dû,
évidemment, comme nous l'avons tous
demandé,
expulser des diplomates,
non, surtout donner l'accueil donner
l'accueil à Snowden, l'asil à Snowden
qui est qui est une personne une belle
personne dans tout ça en plus qui tient
bon et qui est aujourd'hui dans une
sorte d'otage. Moi, je ne ferai pas
confiance à monsieur Poutine, vu comment
il traite, y compris les dissidences
dans son pays, hein, sur la façon dont
un jour il peut peut-être utiliser
Snowden comme monnaie d'échange au
pouvoir russe en tout cas. Mais Snowden
reste ferme et il lui il n'a pas cédé
sur son indépendance quand il y a eu des
répressions contre des homosexuel par
exemple à Moscou. Il l'a fait savoir sur
les réseaux sociaux hein, il a gardé sa
liberté de parole. Mais je reviens, lui
Snowden qui avait pas 30 ans, reprenons
Julien Assange quand il avant
l'invention de Wikileak, quand il est à
cœur euh au euh en Australie, c'est lui
qui a la première idée. Il dit c'est pas
possible. Dans ce monde globalisé, tout
est fait pour nous dire Tina, there is
no alternative. pouvez pas tout ça,
c'est tout interconnecté, l'argent,
l'armée, la puissance, vous allez pas
vous en sortir. Et lui, il dit "Mais
non, on a une arme libératrice qui est
cette révolution technologique." Et il
dit "Au fond, on va les bombarder
d'information.
On va montrer que le roi est nu avec
cette arme pacifique." L'info, l'info.
Et c'est ça qu'il a fait. Et quand il a
pensé ça, il n'avait pas 30 ans. Alors
après, on peut discuter sur comment ça
s'est fait, mais l'utopie est là.
L'information libératrice, le savoir
libérateur, pas le complotisme, pas
l'opinion qui va faire des raisonnements
foireux. Attention hein, la liberté
c'est les faits. La liberté c'est la
connaissance. La liberté c'est le
savoir. La liberté c'est ce puzzle qui
me donne du sens. Et ce puzz, il est
composé de petites pièces qui sont des
vérités de fê recoupées, sourcé,
documenté. Et ça c'est une bataille très
importante parce que aujourd'hui notre
adversaire utilisé par les pouvoirs qui
soient politiques et économiques, c'est
un paradoxe, c'est une autre liberté
qu'il retourne à leur profit, la liberté
d'opinion. Au fond, c'est pour ça qu'il
s'en prennent aux journalistes. Le blab
blabla des opinions, ça les dérange pas,
y compris qu'il y a des choses terrible
qui peut être dit. Ça les dérange
d'autant moins. On l'a documenté sur
Mediapart par exemple en marche à une
pratique totalement absence de toute
déontologie dans la pratique des réseaux
sociaux.
Des botes,
des fake news, des fausses nouvelles,
des bots, des comptes anonymes. On a
montré ça. On n'est pas les seuls. Sans
aucune déontologie. les mêmes qui disent
he il faut
faire des lois pour les
il faut faire des lois et tout mais en
fait ce qui les dérange c'est l'info.
C'est l'info hein le cheval de 3 de la
destruction
de notre émancipation c'est un monde où
il n'y aurait que mon opinion contre la
tienne. Donc très vite mon identité
contre la tienne, ma communauté contre
la tienne la guerre de tous contre tous.
Nous, notre bataille notre bataille à
tous, tous les acteurs, pas seulement
les journalistes professionnels, ceux
qui obtiennent des informations, ceux
qui nous permettent de les avoir, nos
sources, les lanceurs d'alerte aussi.
C'est pour ça que c'est secret des
sources qu'ils veulent essayer de mettre
en cause euh et est essentiel. Et bien,
notre bataille, c'est savoir, ce droit
de savoir. Le droit de savoir et la
liberté de dire sont deux libertés qui
préexistent. qui préexig, je le répète,
euh euh à l'exercice du droit de vote.
Je reprends la parole.
Je vous en prie, je suis un peu bavard.
Il y a il y a un verre d'eau juste à
votre droite si vous voulez si tu veux.
Euh euh on on parle beaucoup de la
défiance de de l'opinion publique contre
les journalistes. Comment comment ça
s'explique, pourquoi ? Comment c'est
arrivé ? Qu'est-ce qui a amené cette
suspicion envers les journalistes ? Pas
tous. Heureusement, il y en a encore qui
font leur travail.
cette cette vraiment défiance profonde
qui
amène le doute et qui pousse les gens à
à aller voir d'autres d'autres sources
d'informations qui sont peut-être moins
crédibles.
Hélas,
les journalistes y ont mis du leur. Là,
il y a une crise de confiance profonde
cette crise de confiance et elle est au
cœur de la raison pour laquelle les
trois journalistes fondateurs de Méia
Part, nous étions connus au monde dans
la crise de la presse traditionnelle,
nous avons créé Médiapart qui est
aujourd'hui dans la presse en ligne et
face au reste de la presse le journal,
le seul je dirais journal totalement
participatif hein où on peut commenter,
bloguer librement, sans modération. euh
qui bloque a priori euh on peut
critiquer le journal, on peut le
prolonger, on peut le discuter, on peut
l'alerter. Alors que c'est quoi cette
crise de confiance ? Et ce que je vous
disais un peu tout à l'heure, dans la
panique qui s'est prise avec la la
révolution digitale numérique, les
médias eux-mêmes ont basculé dans ce
monde de l'opinion, dans ce monde où ils
savent ce qui est bon pour le peuple, où
ils savent voilà,
c'est la police de la pensée.
Je dis pas des termes comme ça, c'est le
blab blabla des opinions. C'est c'est
regarder ces chaînes d'info en continue.
Quand moi j'ai commencé dans le métier,
des figures comme Zemmour, ça n'existait
pas. Non pas que ça n'existait pas
idéologiquement, mais ça n'existait pas
des gens dont la seule légitimité était
de blablater leurs opinions, fut-elle
des opinions scandaleuses, en
l'occurrence xénophobe, raciste,
sexiste, homophobe et cetera. C'est il
fallait être légitime par notre travail
d'information. Et donc il y a il y a il
y a eu ça, ce conformisme, ce suivisme
sans sans aucune autocritique.
Oui. En fait, sur comment dire comme une
pente de facilité et dans un moment où
en plus la crise économique a fait que
ces journaux ont perdu leur indépendance
économique. L'indépendance économique,
c'est important hein. Il y a des gens
très bien au monde, à Libération, au
Figaro et ailleurs. Mais il y a aussi
des gens très mauvais ou
et surtout il y a un écosystème qui
n'est pas le même que dans un journal
comme Mediapart.
C'est un é un écosystème de bocal
contraint contraint contraint parce que
quand même il y a voilà il y a il y a ce
fil nous nous on dit nous seuls nos
lecteurs peuvent nous acheter.
Un jour un jour j'ai une discussion avec
un des membres de la famille Serbant
Schrebert. Je lui ai objecté la la
condition de Julian Assange. C'est en en
2012. Il m'a dit "Moi, durant ma longue
carrière, je n'ai jamais senti la laisse
du pouvoir se tendre sur le collier des
journalistes."
H
ça se tend encore la laisse du pouvoir
sur les journalistes au 21e siècle ?
Bien sûr que ça se tend. Bien sûr qu'
même si qu'on est indépendant, on essaie
de faire pression. Je vous ai parlé de
de de cette tentative de perquisition.
Quel est l'enjeu ? L'enjeu, c'est que
nous journalistes, on doit reconquérir
cette confiance. Et comment on doit la
reconquérir ? En montrant qu'on se bat.
où qu'on soit en montrant qu'on se bat
pour son indépendance. Vous avez un bel
exemple cette semaine. Les sociétés de
journalistes après les révélation de
Médiapart sur l'espionnage de François
Ruffin et de Fakir par le groupe LVMH.
Comme par hasard, les deux journaux qui
appartiennent à monsieur Bernard Arnaud
n'en ont pas parlé, les Échos et le
Parisien. Et bien les sociétés de
journalistes des échos et du Parisien
ont protesté et elles ont rejoint la
protestation globale tout comme sur la
la DGSI et la convocation de notre
coneur du monde qui faisait suite à
Disclose, qui faisait suite à Miaapart.
Il y a eu un point commun, il faut se
battre. La clé est se battre. Il faut se
battre et accepter d'être descendu de
l'estrade, d'être critiqué, d'être
discuté, de rendre compte. Rendre
compte. Ça a l'air tout bête. Mais par
exemple Media Part est un journal où
vous avez tous les comptes chaque année.
Vous connaissez tout l'actionnariat, il
est transparent.
L'actionnariat, il y a toujours Niel
chez vous. Je reprends.
C'est le boutillon qui a qui a Je sais
pas pourquoi Brand Branco euh a voulu
faire une fixette là-dessus. C'est très
simple hein. J'ai tout ça est public
depuis le début. Il y a aucun scoop.
Tout ça va être dénoué d'ailleurs cette
année. Méia part a une société des amis
he qui a été créée inventée en 2008.
C'était pas le Niel d'aujourd'hui hein,
c'était le Niel que connaissait Laurent
Chemla figure que vous connaissez hein
qui c'était le Niel d'avant le
basculement dans l'oligarchie totale et
donc il est un des 88 contributeurs à la
société des amis de Méiap dans lesquels
il y a des gens comme vous et moi et
cetera et le reste comme vous savez
c'est le pôle d'indépendance c'est nous
les fondateurs, la société des salariés
tout ça va être débouclé cette année
pour le rachat de tout le capital de
médi Part par une société à but non
lucratif. Donc et évidemment, je le
rappelle à chaque fois bah quand Niel a
pris le monde et qu'il a pris Free à la
fois et ben qu'afé Médiia part ? Ben, on
a fait une enquête de cinq volets de
Martine Orange et Laurent Moui qui sont
vraiment costaud et qui n'a pas du tout
plu à Monsieur Niel et on a fait notre
boulot comme on le fait toujours. Bon,
donc je regrette ça parce que ça a
beaucoup troublé beaucoup de gens
puisque le livre de Brco a un gros
succès et au lieu de rassembler des
forces, ça crée des polémiques inutiles
hein. Je dire vraiment s'il y a un
journal qui est pas à la main des
oligarques, les révélations sur Bernard
Arnaud, je le répète cette semaine,
elles sont où ? Ils sont sur
Mediapartin. Donc voilà et et on fait on
fait notre boulot. Donc je reviens la
transparence sur tout ce qu'on fait le
fait de rendre compte il y a des moments
dans l'histoire de médiia part depuis 11
ans où des des traitements de médiapart,
des révélations de médiia part des
prises de position parfois de médiia
part n'ont pas plu à une partie de nos
lecteurs. Certains ont dit bah du coup
je me désabonne. D'autres ont dit je
reste parce que vos infos me plaisent
bien mais ça c'est pas bien. Bah il
s'exprime dans Media Peint, vous pouvez
trouver des billets de blog qui
critiquent le directeur de Media Pear
qui critique. Voilà, c'est possible ça.
C'estàd il faut je dis ça parce que vous
savez on parle aujourd'hui,
regardez la régression, la contreéforme
libération
plus de commentaires. Il y a pas de
commentaire sur libération. Depuis 1 an
tout le monde a oublié mais on peut plus
commenter un article sur libération. Il
n'y a plus que 40 blogs qui sont que des
blogs professionnels invités. Il n'y a
pas de blog d'abonnés de médi de
libération. Le monde commentait
seulement trois commentaires par article
de 500 signes maximum, soit au total
1500 signes et ils sont filtrés a priori
par une société de prestataires dont les
personnels sont au Maroc.
Alors même si j'ai quelques problèmes
avec le monde parce que on se taquine un
peu, je pense qu'on peut mettre plus de
commentaires sur le sur les articles du
monde mais il faut être abonné.
Non même en étant abonné.
Même en étant abonné. C'est trois
commentaires. On ne peut commenter que
quand qu'en étant abonné.
C'est fini hein, il faut être abonné et
je l'ai fait pour essayer de répondre
parfois préciser des choses sur des
articles concernés médiaspintes. Je
répète seulement trois commentaires de
500 signes maximum. C'est modéré en
dehors du monde pas par des
journalistes. Donc votre commentaire
numéro 3, s'il suivait le raisonnement
du commentaire numéro 2, pouvez vous
retrouver au fait qu'il soit publié
avant le numéro 2. C'est
incompréhensible. Mais mieux que ça, le
monde a annoncé
que le 5 juin là, ils ferment tous les
blogs de tous leurs abonnés et il
supprime tous les contenus et il ne
gardent que des blogs invités. Que des
blogs invités
qu'on peut
que des blogs invités c'estàdire des
blogs de VIP ce voilà hein les sachants.
Les sachant
qui respectent la liéd les sachants. Les
sachants. C'est fini pouvait plus. et
ils viennent de sortir une nouvelle
charte de participation plus raide.
Voilà, aujourd'hui, je le redis, je le
redis parce que c'est une vraie
bataille. Nous, on s'appelle Méia Part
parce que médiia participatif. On est
aujourd'hui le seul journal
d'information politique et générale don
qui est au cœur quand même maintenant
avec 160000 abonnés par rapport à
réellement individuel payant.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Vous gagnez
combien ?
Comme on gagne combien
vous ? Vous gagnez combien ? Ah
moi mon salaire est public. mon salaire
net avant impôt, c'est 6000 € hein. Euh
et au total la hiérarchie des salaires à
Média par, donc ça fait 7700 7700 bruts,
euh mon
la hiérarchie des salaires à Média Part
3,8 aujourd'hui. de 1 à 3,8, il y a 87
salariés et Méiapart est une entreprise
profitable
qui va de fait être contrôlée par ses
salariés encore plus avec le progressif
départ des fondateurs. Voilà. Non, on a
essayé à Médiapart d'avoir un mode aussi
de gestion où on fait pas les fous où
c'est très bien de gagner un gagnant
6000 € net. Je suis un privilégié, je
suis au-dessus du lot. Voilà, je sais
évidemment qu'à mon âge et avec une
histoire professionnelle comme la
mienne, j'aurais pu voilà mais non, j'ai
vu un des journaux où plus les journaux
étaient en crise, plus arrivaient des
cadres qui disaient "Pour gérer ta
crise, je me paye." et qui faisait
exploser des salaires mais de malade
quoi. C'est pas c'est pas normal. Il
un conseil de déontologie chez Media
Part,
il y a une charte de déontologie hein,
qui est en accès libre. Il y a des
déclarations d'intérêt dans chaque
biographie des journalistes. Puisqu'on
dénonce les conflits d'intérêt des
autres, et ben nous, on doit déclarer
nos intérêts. La charte de déontologie,
vous pouvez la trouver en ligne. Il y a
une charte de participation aussi sur
pour pour ceux qui qui contribuent. Il y
a évidemment les organes sociaux
normals, il y a une société des
journalistes,
comment dire, il y a un fonctionnement
horizontal. Nous avons été en pointe
avec notamment le travail de l'énaï
Bredou sur les violences sexuelles.
L'affaire beaupin et d'autres. Elle
vient encore de faire une enquête sur
les violences sexuelles à l'université.
Évidemment la Ligue du LOL, évidemment
d'autres univers, Luc Besson, le cinéma
et cetera. Et ben du coup, toutes ces
enquêtes nous ont amené à discuter en
interne. Est-ce que nous on est au clair
là-dessus ? Est-ce qu'il y a des alertes
sur des situations de harcèlement
à libérer la parole chez nous aussi, à
prendre parfois des décisions
douloureuses ? On l'a fait, on l'a fait
d'emblé hein. On s'est dit on ne peut
pas pratiquer ça et ne pas C'est ce que
je dis sur la transparence. C'est pas
c'est ça a l'air bête ça. Mais vous ne
pouvez pas à la fois dire je suis un
journalisme d'enquête, je révèle ce
qu'on fait de l'argent public. Je révèle
s'il y a des conflits d'intérêt sans
vous dire bah je dois je suis un
journal, ben je dis à mes lecteurs,
seuls nos lecteurs peuvent nous acheter.
Ben je dois leur rendre des comptes. Ils
doivent pouvoir tout savoir sur ce qu'on
fait. Euh revenons à à notre leader
politique Emmanuel Macron.
Oui.
Euh euh
qui cause sur YouTube en même temps,
mais on est en train de le battre là là.
Normalement, il a fini
il était chez un chez un youtubeur
facilement gérable.
Oui oui oui
oui oui. C'est ce que les communiquants
disent hein. Qu'on est facile à gérer,
c'est que là on peut s'arranger hein.
Me faites pas perdre mon fil. OK. Euh
euh donc Macron Castaner Castaner qui
fait une fake news devant tout le monde
avec l'hôpital de la salle pétitrière.
Le tribunal dit "Caster ne fait pas de
fake news."
Hm.
On fait comment pour combattre ça ?
Est-ce queon
alors les députés qui ont fait ça, ils
ont fait ça pour montrer que cette loi
était foireuse parce que moi je l'aurais
pas fait parce que je suis contre cette
loi. Donc je vais pas demander
pourquoi vous êtes contre la loi fake
news.
Ah mais c'est c'est une loi contre la
liberté de la presse comme la loi sur le
secret des affaires.
Mais c'est une loi tout d'un vous rendez
compte dans notre monde actuel la
première priorité du président de la
République a été de demander une loi sur
les fausses nouvelles en période
électorale.
Peur de faire manipuler par une
puissance étrange. Voilà, il disent les
bout rus, ils vont faire et cetera. Donc
nous les journalistes, nous les
journalistes, on leur dit quoi ?
On dit "Vous nous dites que c'est les
boots russes, que c'est ceci et que ça
ne concerne pas notre travail." Alors,
il suffit que vous l'écriviez. Suffit
que ça ne concerne pas le travail normal
d'information des journalistes qui
relèvent de la loi de 1881
et pas un type qui un juge seul qui est
en référé en 24 heures va dire "C'est
faux ou vrai." Donc nous, on leur dit
"Inscrivez-le dans la loi." C'est
curieux, ils ont pas voulu l'inscrire.
Alors, je vais vous dire pourquoi.
Rappelez-vous la présidentielle de 2012,
il y a 15 jours entre le 1er et le 2e
tour, le samedi du milieu,
sortez une petite affaire,
bah, on sort le document liben, le
financement de SarkoZi, on sort là pas
parce qu'on attendait un calendrier
électoral parce que c'était prê à Non,
non, c'est moi, nous on est comme des
cuisiniers.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable. Non, bien
sûr, mais on va pas faire du réchauffé
dans un four à micro-ondes. Donc quand
c'est prêt, ça sort. Il se trouve bon,
ça c'est sorti là. Alors, on a une cette
discussion. J'avais dit si je le gère
politiquement, je pourrais être accusé
dans un sens ou dans l'autre d'avoir
instrumentalisé cette info. Donc, je la
sors quand elle est prête. Que dit
monsieur Sarkozy ? Fake news, faux et
usage de faux.
Il aurait eu cette loi référée référée
24 he ça
référé et à l'époque Média part est en
avance sur tout le monde toute la presse
du mot ce document ça a pas l'air de
document libien non
c'est pas qu'ils font la fine bouche il
nous casse quoi. il nous casse, il nous
regarde de haut. On était en 2012 he
depuis Media Part est plus respecté par
la profession
n'y croit pas.
Il y a jamais de solidarité entre votre
profession
si de regardez, je vous ai parlé de ces
solidarités qui existent. Ça se
construit si les journalistes se
battent. Le courage est contagieux. Si
on se bat, on donne l'exemple, même si
on on se fait taper, même si on est
parfois vaincu, déçu, ça aide les autres
à se battre. C'est moi. Voilà. et qu'on
soit au Figaro, à BFM, à TF1 ou
ailleurs, on doit se battre pour
l'honneur de son métier. On n'est pas au
service du patron, on n'est pas au
service du pouvoir, on est au service
des citoyens. Donc je reviens sur
l'histoire. Donc rendez-vous compte,
cette loi aurait existé. Sarkozy
réussissait à tuer par une décision d'un
magistrat. Et l'affaire Bismut vous
prouve que parfois
on a hein c'est le pseudo qu'il a pris
comme dans les les histoires un peu
mafieuse pour essayer d'instrumentaliser
la justice dans des coups de fil. Et
bien bon, le magistrat disait bah non
voilà parce que quand même il y a eu 4
ans d'information judiciaire pour
authentifier le document d'expertise en
40 en 24 heures. Vous le faisiez pas et
nous on avait pas de témoin. Vous voyez
le bordel libyen à l'époque à sortir
hein, c'était ça se faisait pas en 24
heures. Donc il pouvait en 24 heures
tuer l'info. En 24 heures tuer l'info.
Donc s'ils ne l'ont pas voulu mettre que
ça ne concernait pas les journalistes
professionnels, c'est bien pour ça
qu'ils ont cette arrièrepensée. Et du
coup eux peuvent faire des fausses
nouvelles comme monsieur Trump n'arrête
pas d'en faire mais Castaner c'est
énorme. Mais il y a pas que Castan.
Regardez comment madame Nathalie
l'oiseau leur tête de liste a réagi sur
nos infos légitimes. Le passé de
quelqu'un qui est en politique c'est
normal qu'on s'y intéresse. On s'est
intéressé et c'est moi qui ai fait ça au
monde au passé de François Mitteran
quand il était d'extrême droite ou sous
l'occupation. On s'est intéressé et
c'est aussi moi qui avais fait ça au
passé caché Trotskis de Lionel Jospin.
On a fait tout ça. Donc on raconte qu'en
effet elle a copiné, engagé, accepté sur
une liste de droite extrême et d'extrême
droite à Sciencep dans sa jeunesse. Bon
ben, il suffisait qu'elle reconnaisse.
Il fallait pas qu'elle nie aurait la
nier et puis après s'est en berlificoté
et du coup elle m'a traité de maoïste je
vois pas ce que rapport vous voyez la la
dégradation du débat politique la haine
du journalisme. Nous on fait notre
travail il y a pas besoin de nous donner
des noms d'oiseaux. Moi je n'insulte pas
madame l'oiseau en l'occurrence hein. Je
n'insulte pas les politiques. Je le
traite pas. Je respecte leur travail
mais nous sommes, c'est ça une culture
démocratique hein. Il faut accepter la
légitimité des uns et des autres. Donc
je je continue parce que il y a il y a
le truc était énorme de Castaner et on
l'a tout de suite montré et on a montré
que vous avez vu que le mensonge sur la
pitié il est à c'était un mensonge comme
les poupées gigoges puisqu'on a terminé
par le fait que le le vrai scandale
qu'on a voulu étouffer c'est que les
policiers sont rentrés y compris dans
une résidence universitaire. Ils ont
tapé
ils ont tapé un étudiant qui n'osait pas
porté plainte parce qu'il
il avait pas la bonne couleur.
Il avait pas la bonne couleur. Donc du
coup on s'efface et cetera. Mais on a
montré la vidéo, hein, et les
voltigeurs, hein, euh, qui ont été
recréés à l'époque, hein. C'est ces
unités mixtes, celles qui ont qui ont
provoqué et le résultat la mort de
Malikusekin. Et donc je continue parce
que vous voyez la l'autre loi qui a fait
passer ce pouvoir qui est aussi une loi
contre la liberté de la presse, c'est la
loi sur le secret des affaires
qui n'était pas contrairement ils ont
toujours ils instrumentalisent l'Europe.
C'est eux qui font le discours de
discrédit de l'Europe parce que pour
faire cette loi, ils ont dit l'Europe
nous y oblige. On a regardé, c'est pas
vrai. Il y a une directive très
discutable sur le le secret des affaires
au niveau européen, mais elle
n'obligeait pas à faire tout de suite
une loi en France. et ils ont fait une
loi qui va au-delà. La loi dit que le
secret des affaires des entreprises,
elle le définit comment et secret ce que
l'entreprise a dit que c'est secret.
C'est intéressant ça. C'est une
définition totologique. Et elle confie
au tribunal de commerce, ça rien à voir
avec la presse. Tribunal de commerce,
c'est le business avec parfois des
choses un peu bizarres. Le droit d'être
saisi en disant tiens Mediapart révèle
des choses qui viennent du conseil
d'administration qui viennent et cetera.
Et bien, c'est un tribunal de commerce
qui va qui va trancher là-dessus.
Pareil, on leur a dit, ils nous ont dit
c'est les Chinois, là c'était pas les
Russes hein, c'est les Chinois, c'est
l'espionnage économique chinois. On dit
très bien, dites que ça ne concerne pas
le travail normal, légitime, la liberté
fondamentale, le droit de savoir, la
liberté d'information des citoyens. Ils
n'ont pas voulu le mettre. Pourquoi ?
parce que évidemment que ça sert à
protéger les intérêts dont ils sont
aujourd'hui dépendants. Tous ces lobby
économiques, ce qui a provoquer la
démission de Nicolas Hullot. tout ce
qu'on sait, c'est-à-dire la présence des
lobby au cœur du pouvoir. Et vous en
avez eu une preuve quand il y a eu ces
révélations sur un scandale
pharmaceutique, sur les implants et
cetera où le secret des affaires a été
évoqué et vous rendez compte c'est pour
montrer notre travail un un une grande
entreprise en secret prépare un grand
plan de licenciement en mentant aux
organisations syndicales. nous obtenons
les documents, c'est d'intérêt public,
c'est la vie de travailleur qui est
concerné. Et donc le secret des fafires
ne vaut pas dans ce cas-là parce que ça
veut dire que on utilise ce secret en le
privatisant et au détriment de
personnes. Donc et ça on doit en rendre
compte si on nous poursuit encore une
fois dans le cadre de la loi sur la
liberté de la presse. Et donc vous voyez
plein d'affaires que Méia Part a sorti
concernent le business. Donc là là on
est 33e rang sur la liberté de la presse
souvent report
même pas 34e là 33 je me demande si
c'est pas 34e à
ouais on va dire 33 34 l'année
prochaine. La Suisse est 6e
Oui. Et
avec toutes ces affaires de violence
policière de de perquisition de de de
tir de LBD sur les journalistes de de
garde à vue préventive et des choses
comme ça, le droit de la presse, il est
encore assuré. la
c'est c'est la question, c'est ce que je
voudrais vraiment dire à tous cible
vraiment les les
justement c'est ce que je voudrais dire.
Vous m'avez posé la question tout à
l'heure sur la confiance. Dire à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui qui nous
écoutent que c'est si on dit c'est la
presse, on va dire c'est un truc corpo.
Vous voyez, c'est les journalistes qui
se battent pour les journalistes. Et
moi, c'est pas mon problème là
parce que le journalisme est aussi un
champ de bataille. Moi je me bats contre
un certain journalistes de gouvernement,
une presse d'industrie
tout ce que vous voulez. Il y en a
beaucoup des comme ça, non ? à une
bataille. Bah oui, voilà. Bah, on se bat
hein, on se bat dans toutes sortes de
milieux professionnels. Ce que je veux
dire, c'est que nous notre métier est au
cœur d'un droit qui vous appartient.
C'est pour ça que encore une fois la
critique du journalisme est légitime. La
haine des médias et du journalisme, ça
c'est autre chose. Quand vous les mettez
tous en bloc, quand vous les cognez,
quand vous les frappez, ça c'est autre
chose. Parce que là, vous vous attaquez
vous-même. Vous vous attaquez vous-même.
Et sincèrement, quel est l'enjeu
derrière ça ? Et je vous le redis, les
apporteurs de vérité de fait, ces
informations sont vues par des pouvoirs
autoritaires comme plus dangereux que
les opposants politiques. Quand Erdogan
fait son coup de force en Turquie, les
premiers qui frappent c'est les
journalistes. C'est les journalistes
qu'il criminalisent et y compris pour
certains, il les condamnent, il les fait
condamner à de la perpétuité. Et donc
c'est vraiment le la question de la
culture démocratique.
Question d'internet, a-t-il suffisamment
de pluralisme dans la caste des
journalistes ? Moi, je dirais pas à la
CTE, on est des travailleurs de
l'information. La Cast euh il y a
beaucoup de journalistes hein, il euh
ils gagnent il marnent, ils ont des
idéaux, euh ils les défendent, euh ils
essayent de faire au mieux, euh ils sont
syndiqués, euh ils
soivent des commandes.
Oui. Puis mais aussi d'accord, mais ce
que je veux dire, c'est quand même il y
a des travailleurs et des travailleuses
de l'information, hein. Voilà. Oui. Ben,
il y en a plein question. Donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que voilà, si on dit la
caste, on fait un bloc comme ça et et on
on tombe à mon avis dans dans comment
dire pas dans le bon chemin de la
bataille, quoi. Je je vous entends tout
à fait,
mais on sent le public qui qui a cette
sensation de trahison de son 4e pouvoir,
de cette politique de cours, de cette de
ce journaliste de ce journaliste qui
reste sous le robinet de l'information
du politique, de ce journaliste qui qui
sert la main avant l'entrée d'Emmanuel
Macron. Vous je comprends mais vous vous
adressez vous vous adressez à la
mauvaise adresse. Moi nous nous nous on
mais oui nous on montre nous le succès
de médiia part
c'est parce que les autres faisaient pas
leur boulot.
Leur succès de médiia part c'est de
montrer que si on fait ce chemin là si
on donne le moyen de l'indépendance tout
en n'étant pas démagogue en faisant nous
on fait notre travail et j'assume
parfois que si certaines informations
dérangent une partie de nos lecteurs,
ben elles sont voilà je vais pas cacher
des informations qui dérangent une
partie parce qu'elles plaisent à
d'autres et ainsi de suite. Bon donc
qu'est-ce que ça fait ? a fait qu'on
construit la confiance. Vous savez, en
plein mouvement gilets jaunes, certes,
il y a eu des incid parler des gilets
jaunes parce qu'on va encore nous
accuser de surfer sur les gilets jaunes.
Mais non, nous on parle des gilets
jaunes. Nous on n'arrête pas
et et on on continue. Et ben qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qui s'est passé le
lendemain de la perquisition ? Il y a
une manifestation spontanée de gilets
jaunes au pied de Médiap, hein. Donc la
confiance, elle est là. Moi, je tourne
beaucoup autour. J'ai fait un bouquin à
partir du travail de de Media Partil
jaunes, la victoire des vaincus. On a un
film qui est sorti qui montre le travail
de Méia Part qui s'appelle depuis
Médiapart. Les salles sont pleines. Il y
a 500 300 personnes. Il y a des débats,
on est là, on discute.
Le décodex,
oui,
c'est bien le décodex, c'est pas bien
décodex. Et puis euh,
il y a il y a celui qui existe à à Libé
et celui cheake news à Libé, décodex,
c'est le monde et cetera. Alors, c'est
comment dire ? C'est c'est très ambigu.
C'est ambigu parce que c'est un côté
d'abord maintenant on va avant de
produire des infos, on va s'occuper de
vérifier les infos des autres. Bon,
c'est utile, ça permet des mises au
point et et ceux qui font ça euh le font
très sérieusement, hein, plutôt euh et
de manière très précise. Ça permet euh
notamment euh de montrer euh que le
pouvoir euh raconte euh souvent
n'importe quoi. Une des ambiguités pour
moi, c'est que dans les médias en
question, c'est payé par qui ? Facebook
par Facebook, c'estd c'est tout le
problème c'est tout le problème de la
dépendance des gafas, c'est-à-dire d'un
plus, il y a les aides publiques à la
presse que nous refusons et qui est un
scandale. Le premier bénéficiaire, c'est
le groupe de Bernard Arnaud, le deuxè
c'est monsieur Drahi, le 3è c'est les
autres Niel et d'autres euh ils sont
riches hein, il y a pas de raison qu'ils
reçoivent des subventions directes euh
pour leurs journaux. Ils ont qu'à mettre
de leur poche et par ailleurs s'écumuler
avec le fait que les GAFA, Google euh et
Facebook et d'autres euh font des aides
pour faire passer le fait qu'ils payent
pas tout à fait leurs impôts, hein,
quand même. C'est ça la réalité. Donc
moi, je n'aime pas trop cette dépendance
mais
en clair et je n'aime pas comment dire
là, il y a un vrai débat. Facebook
c'est le piège. Tout le monde l'utilise
mais c'est le piège. Facebook vous êtes
le produit. Facebook je l'algorithme
vous calcule en fonction des opinions,
pas des infos. Ils ont créé un monstre
et d'ailleurs on l'a vu, trafic des
données, Cambridge Analytica, campagne
Trump et tout. C'est ça le vrai scandale
en l'occurrence. Et du coup qu'est-ce
qu'ils font maintenant ? Ils appellent
eux-mêmes au secours les États Facebook.
Marc Zuckerbert, il va voir les États.
Aidez-nous à contrôler tout ça. Et donc
il y a une alliance entre ces monstre
économique et les États pouvoir
autoritaires
pour le contrôle de tout ça. Et en
l'occurrence, je vais peut-être vous
surprendre quand j'insistant sur le côté
participatif de Médiapard, c'est pour
vous dire que nous parmi nos projets
fous après avoir installé Médiapart
comme un journal indépendant avec son
copé Robin des Bois de l'investigation,
bah c'est dire quittez Facebook, venez à
Mediapart. C'est un réseau social Méia
part, vous aurez pas d'algorithme, vous
aurez pas de pub, vous serez pas le
produit, vous serez pas piégé. Alors on
a du travail he pour que ce soit que ce
soit techniquement techniquement au
point mais mais là il y a il y a il y a
il y a une vraie bataille sur la la
crise de de cet univers.
Je voudrais je voudrais qu'on revienne
sur l'uniformisation de la de la presse,
l'unanimisme de la presse sur certains
sujets. Je vais vous donner comme
exemple Trump, l'élection de Trump.
Tous les médias, 95 % des médias nous
disaient que
il n'allait pas remporter et que c'était
Clinton qui allait le remporter. sont
lamentablement plantés. Comment vous
expliquez ça ? C'est parce que ils sont
dans leur bocal. Ils sont dans leur
bocal. Ils sont tous à se relayer. Ils
font de la propagande,
ils travaillent pour des intérêts
autres.
Non, je pense que ça c'est aussi vieux
que la presse. Simplement on le voit. On
le voit. Pourquoi ? parce que la c'est
tout l'enjeu, tout ce que nous utilisons
là qui est qui est récent entre nous, il
y a une décennie de massification de
tous les instruments dont nous parlons.
Méia par secret en 2008, c'est l'année
où Facebook et YouTube et et et Twitter
commence à exploser. Le smartphone, il
est créé en 2007, hein, son 2007. Les
tablettes n'existaient pas, le
crowdfunding existait pas encore. Donc
nous sommes nous sommes nous avons une
grosse décennie, il y a eu une décennie
de hein, les hackurs, les pionniers,
ceux qui faisaient du code. Il y a eu
une deuxième décennie avec l'idée ça y
est, on va conquérir et là on est dans
le temps du backlash hein, la
contreréforme hein et on voit d'autres
dispositifs. Donc on est dans le temps
d'une bataille. Toute révolution
technologique appelle une révolution
démocratique. C'était le cas avec la
machine à vapeur, c'était le cas avec
l'électricité qui ont toutes été des
révolutions aussi de l'information.
La nécessité des journalistes sur la
campagne de Trump. Oui, mais je j'y
reviens. Ça veut dire que aujourd'hui,
grâce à cette horizontalité, cette
immédiateté, ce temps réel, le fait
qu'il y ait du suivisme journalistique,
le fait qu'il y ait du conformisme
journalistique, le fait que l'idéologie
dominante soit toujours ou prou
dominante, que ce soit en Chine, que ce
soit à Moscou et que ce soit ailleurs,
hein, attention, c'est partout, vous le
voyez. Donc vous vous dites c'est pas
possible, il nous faut l'alternative, il
nous faut le pluralisme. Ben c'est cette
bataille qu'il faut mener. Faut pas se
plaindre. En clair, ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il y a pas de fatalité, il y a
pas de complot, il y a pas une main qui
manipule tout ça derrière. Il y a il y a
nous il y a nous comment on se bat. Il
faut aider la presse indépendante.
Il y a quand même une her class qui a
des intérêts, qui
Bien sûr qu'il y a une lutte des
classes. Bien sûr qu'il y a une lutte
des classes. Il y a il y a Mais
aujourd'hui et les gilets jaunes nous
l'ont rappelé, la vérité c'est qu'il y a
surtout en 30 ans une toute petite
minorité qui est au cœur aujourd'hui du
pouvoir économique et du pouvoir
politique qui a capté tout ça. Bon et
que c'est intenable, c'est
insupportable. Donc donc mais oui ben
donc quel est moi, qu'est-ce que je vois
? Je vois plutôt l'inverse. Je vois que
nous Media Parté.
Je vois que les gilets jaunes, nous on a
tout de suite compris.
Oui. Bah d'accord. Ben d'accord. Donc
donc on est nombreux. Donc faut moi je
vois plutôt cette bouteille là
à regarder en haut se taper le mur. Non
on se bat, on trace notre route quand
même. On va les laisser laissons,
traçons notre route.
Créons créons des solidarités. Créons
des causes communes de légalité. C'est
ça qu'il faut faire. Euh, se lamenter,
comment dire, être dans le ressentiment
qui est une bataille. Bien sûr, que les
idéos démocratiques et sociaux,
la vengeance et le ressentiment n'ont
jamais été de bon conseil. Faut de
l'élévation. Comment c'est ? C'est la
leçon des gilets jaunes pour moi. C'est
l'élévation, la hauteur. Sur les
ronds-points, on demande pas aux gens
d'où ils viennent. On demande pas où ils
ont voté. Le tuto est de rigueur et on
commence à discuter. Et on discute de
quoi ? Bah, de qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
ensemble ? Et qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Même si des gens viennent avec leurs
préjugés, même si des gens avaient voté
à l'extrême droite, tout d'un coup, il
se passe autre chose. Et on entend plus
parler tiens de quoi ? Des migrants, ils
en parlent pas. On entend plus parler
tiens des musulmans, hop, ils en parlent
pas. Tout l'agenda avec lequel on nous
pourrit la tête, le bouquet émissaire
hein, la diversion. Et on parle de quoi
? Des questions démocratiques et
sociales. Et et c'est comme ça que se
font des politisations authentiques du
côté de la démocratie.
Vous y croyez encore ? Mais je crois il
y a la seule chose qu'on peut prédire,
c'est la lutte. Faut se battre.
Autrement à quoi ça sert d'avoir vécu ?
Alors, est-ce qu'il faut voter dimanche
? Question.
Moi, j'ai j'ai aucune consigne à donner
de cet.
Est-ce que vous votez ?
Moi personnellement, je dis jamais ce
que je fais. Pourquoi ? Parce que je
suis le président de Média Part. Donc si
je dis quelque chose, on dira Médiap dit
quelque chose. Donc voilà, à Média Part,
je peux vous dire hein, les débats ont
lieu dans la rédaction et il y en a qui
s'abstiennent. Il y en a qui
s'abstiennent. Il y en a euh qui vont
voter euh Brossa, il y en a qui vont
voter Insoumis, il y en a qui vont voter
euh Jade et alors ceux qui votent Jado,
ils disent "Non, je vote Damien Carem et
cetera." Voilà parce que la diversité de
la liste, chacun voit ce qu'il veut ceux
qui votent à soumis disent "Ah non, je
vote pas à soumis mais Manon Ari parce
que c'est une tête nouvelle et qu'en
vence Mélenchon son sectarisme m'énerve
parfois."
Ceux qui votent Brosa, il disent "Ah ben
je forcément je suis pas forcément
proche du PC mais Brosa a fait une très
bonne campagne et cetera." Bon, il y a
une grande diversité comme ça. Ce qui
est sûr, c'est que autant que je sache,
à Média Part, ça ne vote pas à Front
National et ça ne vote pas en marche.
Personne n'est parfait.
Euh euh cette narration, il y a il y a
vraiment une une presse qui perpétue une
narration qui qui nous raconte cette
petite histoire de de la la fuite en
avant du capitalisme et que il faut
vraiment continuer à travailler à fond
parce que c'est le seul chemin. Euh euh
est-ce que vous croyez réellement qu'
que des petits médias comme le vôtre ou
comme d'autres médias sur internet
peuvent proposer une une alternative à
ces à cette narration, ce rouleau
compresseur où c'est pas possible ?
D'abord, d'abord, je pense qu'ils y
croient de moins en moins à leur
narration parce que il voi combien quand
même la montre tourne l'urgence
climatique et regardez, c'était
aujourd'hui une marche mondiale, les
jeunes collégiens, les collégiens les
plus jeunes montrent le chemin.
Qu'est-ce que dit le GC ? Il nous reste
11 ans et qu'est-ce que dit Hulo qui est
pas un révolutionnaire quand il
démissionne ? cette politique
économique, elle va pas avec ça, c'est
pas possible hein. Bon donc ils sont
beaucoup à croire de moins en moins la
crise est en leur sein. Simplement, il y
a une tête d'épingue qui s'en fout, qui
ne pense qu'à l'immédiat, l'avoir et le
pouvoir. Tant que je dure, c'est c'est
Carlos Gaun quand j'ai mes cinq maisons
dans le monde entier euh payé sur la
bête grâce à la boîte, mon jet privé et
je mets tout le monde au boulot. Mais
moi, je ne croise jamais les gens. J'ai
fait un article la semaine dernière pour
rappeler les chiffres. Aujourd'hui, il y
a une sécession des classes dirigeantes.
Elles ne croisent plus le peuple. Elles
ne le rencontrent plus. Ni là où elles
habitent, ni là où elles vont à l'école,
ni dans leurs loisirs. Donc ils sont
dans leur bulles, mais d'une certaine
manière dans leur bulles, ils peuvent y
croire. Mais quand ils vont dans la
société réelle, et c'est ce qui leur a
pété à la figure avec les gilets jaunes,
ils vont à un monde qu'il ne connaissent
pas. Ça c'est mon premier point. Deuxème
point, on n'est pas petit. On n'est pas
petit.
Médiia part en 11 ans, on est au cœur du
système médiatique. C'est quoi la vérité
des chiffres ? Libération sur tout
support, papier papier numérique chiffre
réel pas les achats en nombre qui sont
dans les avions qui sont bradés pour
l'audience. C'est 50000 nous c'est
160000.
Le monde et le Figaro, chiffre réel, il
il bluffe un peu en bradant les
abonnements, les abonnements les
abonnements numérique. C'est 240 250, on
est à la mo plus de la moitié et et
notre agenda est au cœur du débat
public. Alors, je dis pas ça pour jouer
les biceps, c'est pas ça du tout. Je dis
juste que il y a pas de fatalité, y
compris sur le terrain de l'information.
Il y a pas de fatalité et notre succès
fait bouger. Donne du courage à des gens
qui sont dans ces journaux. et qui du
coup se battent, se mettent en
mouvement.
Quand Libération euh titre en première
page, faites ce que vous voulez mais
voter Macron.
C'est à la presse de faire ça
hm
quand tout tout il y a tout toute cette
presse qui se synchronise pour mettre la
tête de Macron un peu partout.
C'est un débat qui a traversé nos
lecteurs. Comme vous le savez, euh Méia
Part a reçu Macron avant le second tour
et nous-même on a on a dit que on ne
votait pas pour le Front National. Bon
avant le premier tour, beaucoup de gens
l'ont oublié. J'ai écrit que pour moi le
second tour qui est de nos vœux c'était
un second tour Mélenchon Macron. Pour
moi, Fillon était déconsidéré évidemment
au-delà de ses positions politiques par
l'affaire de corruption de fait qui le
concernait. Et l'extrême droite raciste
xénophobe, sans éthique, sans moral,
hein. Les affaires d'argent sont aussi
très présentes au Front National, il
faut le rappeler.
Et dans les autres parties.
Oui. Oui. Mais le Front National,
attention hein, il prétend raser tout
propre, laver tout propre. C'est ils
vivent sur la bête hein. C'était le
papa, c'est la fille. Je sais pas ce qui
en sera de la petite fille mais quand
même on a fait le bilan aujourd'hui
c'est un article sur Media part hein au
fond désolé mais la présence au
Parlement européen a servi qu'à faire du
fric et pas à faire du travail travail
parlementaire.
Donc c'est un vieux parti hein, c'est
pas de la jeune politique hein nouvelle.
Donc je dis ça donc
ça rapporte combien d'être parlement
européen pour
le chiffre exact ? Je sais pas mais ça
c'est bien sûr mais comme d'être
parlementaire, j'ai oublié ça mais je
dirais une bêtise mais les être
parlementaire c'est bien payé et et moi
je ne critique pas ça c'est un coup la
démocratie mais à un condition qu'on
l'utilise pour ce travail là pas pour
son parti de manière partisane. Voilà
soit personnel nous on a révélé les
frais l'utilisation des frais des
députés des sénateurs. C'est nous
médiapart qui avons révélé ça. Et aux
États en Grande-Bretagne, c'est là la
culture démocratique et nous sommes tous
comptables de la culture démocratique.
En Grande-Bretagne, les mêmes
révélations on étaient faites. Ben, les
parlementaires qui ont été pris la main
dans le sac, ne serait-ce que pour 15000
à 20000 € de frais qu'ils avaient
utilisé pour eux, ils ont disparu de la
circulation. Certains ont même fait de
la prison. 6 mois de prison pour l'un
d'entre eux assez connu pour 19000 €.
Pour 19000 € ça a pas fait un pli.
culturellement, on dit bah si vous êtes
élu et que vous utilisez de l'argent
public à des fins privées, paf, et on on
discute pas hein, ça met pas des années
jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait le procès
balcanie et que et cetera ou ça ne met
pas des années de bataille sur beaucoup
d'affaires qui minent la confiance dans
la démocratie. La démocratie, c'est une
culture.
Est-ce qu'on est réellement en
démocratie en France ? On est dans une
démocratie de faible intensité mais pour
une raison pour une raison qui dont nous
sommes tous responsables. Le fait le
fait que nous acceptions le
présidentialisme, ça c'est un des
combats fondateurs de médias peint
nourri par notre travail d'enquête. Nous
devrions être une démocratie
délibérative, parlementaire,
participative.
cette idée archaïque qu'une seule
personne rafle tout au second tour de la
présidentielle et dit pendant 5 ans
aujourd'hui 7 ans hier circuler il y a
rien à voir qui au fond la volonté de
tous est confisquée par le pouvoir d'un
seul et pour moi la belle surprise des
gilets jaunes c'est que c'est un
mouvement qui a posé aussi cette
question
les politiques ont confisqué les
institutions
mais pas les politiques. Il y a des gens
bien dans les politiques. Il y a des
pareil faut pas dire les journalistes.
Faut pas dire les politiques. Mais par
exemple, je sais pas, il y a des gens
qui parfois suivent leurs principees,
leur liberté, leur liberté. Mais
regardez, bah au moment de de de la
déchéance de nationalité, il y en a
certains qui se sont levés. Sur l'état
d'urgence, il y en a certains qui se
sont levés. Regardez même sur l'affaire
Benala, les sénateurs qui font leur
travail d'enquête sur l'affaire Benala.
Regardez Jacques Toubon qui a été un
politique politicien de droite et
regardez-le en défenseur des droits
aujourd'hui. Et c'est impeccable ce
qu'il fait. Donc ne dites pas les
politiques, ne dites pas les journal Non
mais très bien, non, je dis à ceux que
ça les journalistes, voilà, c'est comme
si on voilà, on on crée de l'extériorité
hein, alors que ça Mais je reviens sur
le présidentialisme et c'est tout le
problème. Regardez la dispersion des
listes de gauche pour ces européennes.
Elles vont toutes vous raconter un film
différent mais la clé c'est les
présidentielles.
Quelle grande différence y a-t-il
sincèrement au niveau européen
niveau d'un débat européen où menace ses
droites nationaliste et cetera sur
l'urgence climatique, l'urgence
démocratique, l'urgence sociale,
l'urgence des du combat contre l'évasion
fiscale et je pourrais ajouter l'urgence
de la démocratisation de l'Europe
elle-même.
Si vous prenez ces éléments là,
trouvez-moi des différences radicales
rédibitoires entre la liste
Brosa PC
Aubri France insoumise Amon génération
Europe écologie
François Lino
non je pour François le Brexit le frexit
non moi je suis internationaliste et
médiia part on est internationaliste
vous m'avez demandé des différences bah
il y a il y a la liste as
non mais lui je le mets pas dans les
listes de gauche lui il vient de la
droite et il est profondément et sur les
migrants, il y a vous savez nous on a
des principes nous on défend des
principes des principes hein et les
principes c'est la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme hein.
Désolé nous naissons libre et égau en
droit et parmi le les droits, il y a le
droit de se déplacer. Il y a un hasard
malheureux de la naissance. On a le
droit de choisir son pays de résidence
et donc toutes les forces xénophobes qui
font veulent que les nations ou que
l'Europe elle-même soit une clôture et
une fermeture he sont d'un autre côté.
Je parlais de gens qui partagent des
idéaux démocratiques, sociauistes.
Bon et y compris une partie de la liste
socialiste dans le le discours qu'en
fait Gluxman.
La quoi ?
La liste socialiste de Globaliste.
C'est leur nom. C'est leur nom. Moi
après vous pouvez dire
mais mais il est Gluxman mais moi je
regarde moi sincèrement moi je suis non
croyant hein. Je imaginaire. Non mais et
je ne suis pas je dis juste je dis juste
l'irresponsabilité de ces gens. Il faut
croire ce qu'on raconte ce qu'il raconte
tous
sur l'urgence.
Non mais c'est moi je suis pas dans leur
tête, je dis juste sur l'urgence.
Imaginez qu'il se soit dit quand même
après le le paquet d'eau de mer pris il
y a 2 ans, l'extrême droite au deuxème
tour quand même et Macron qui arrive
dans son chamboulet tout et qui rafle
tout avec 18 % des inscrits au premier
tour. Comment ces gens-là ont pas pu se
mettre autour d'une table arrêtons de
déconner ? OK, on a nos partis, on a nos
mouvements, on a nos intérêts, va y
avoir les européennes. Ça se joue au
niveau européen, hein. On va pas faire
la France de l'Europe. On n'est pas
l'Europe, on va pas la faire à la
française, ça se joue avec d'autres.
Regardez les écolos, ils vont peut-être
gagner en Belgique. Regardez les
résultats en Autriche. Regard, non, au
Pays-Bas, c'est pas en Autriche, c'est
au Pays-Bas hier. Regardez la gauche
espagnole he avec le débat et l'alliance
parfois tumultueuse mais réelle entre
Podemos et les socialistes et avec le
dialogue avec les indépendantistes
catalans. Je pourrais multiplier les
exemples. Comment ces forces là ont pas
pu se dire
on se pose et on voit et du coup la
question du coup. Non mais moi je je dis
juste que c'estable mais la réponse on
l'a tous. Voilà la réponse. Ils se
mettent pas autour d'une table pour
désigner un leader pour se réconcilier
parce qu'ils veulent le pouvoir, le
pognon.
Mais ça mais moi comme moi je reste avec
des idéaux, je veux pas me résoudre à
ça. Je pense pas qu'ils sont tous
mauvais. Je pense pas qu'ils sont tous
sans idé. Ben, je pense qu'ils sont
irresponsables. Ils sont irresponsables.
Je pense que pour face à ce face à face
que construit Macron et que construit le
Front National qui les arrange tous la
peste, le choléra, venez là hein, voilà
qui nous font à nouveau. Il fallait une
autre force, il fallait une union. Et il
fallait une union surtout sur une
élection à un tour, surtout sur une
élection où l'abstention est importante
et là il pouvait y avoir un événement
qui se passe. Alors ils ne le font pas.
Pourquoi ? Le clientélisme, le nombre de
postes, la présidentielle derrière. Mais
en l'occurrence dans le moment actuel,
c'est irresponsable. Je le pense
vraiment. Je je nous médiia part, on
parfois on est comment dire ? Moi je
crois, je l'ai écrit y compris dans non
seulement des articles mais des livres
issus du travail de médiap. On est dans
un moment où il faut faire chemin
commun, les causes communes de
l'égalité. Faut pas faire la petite
querelle des petites différences. Il y a
un libert
John Hollow qui avait fait qui avait
fait cette formule sur les gauches ou
les radicalités. Il disent voilà c'est
un peu comme dans un film d'horreur
voyez film d'horreur. Vous êtes dans une
pièce comme celle-ci et les murs sont là
et ils se rapprochent ils se
rapprochent. Non, les murs se
rapprochent. Les murs se rapprochent. Et
pendant ce temps-là, les gauches
discutent de la répartition des meubles.
Bah ouais. Question d'internet. Pourquoi
les Panama Papers n'ont pas eu l'impact
qu'ils auraient dû avoir ?
Il y a eu pas mal d'impact des Panama
Papers mais de beaucoup d'autres leaks
hein puisque nous on en a fait pas mal.
les Football Leaks, les Malta Files, il
y a eu les Luxaks, il y a eu aussi ce
qu'on a révélé sur le groupe Pino et
cetera. Il y a eu un impact quand même
sur la prise de conscience de l'ampleur
de l'évasion fiscale,
sur l'action du coût des États. Je
prends sur le groupe Pino par exemple
qui dit sa générosité pour Notre-Dame
grâce aux révélations de Médiapart avec
le consortium EIC, il s'est reçu une une
amende de près de 3 milliards du fisque
italien. 3 milliards 3 milliards et ça
n'a pas les révélations datent d'il y a
un an hein et quand on les a sortis Pino
a dit tout est en règle tu parles tout
est en règle bon donc le groupe Kiring
hein de voilà de la famille Pinot donc
je crois que euh comment dire vous savez
j'ai c'est un activiste burkinabé qui
m'a rendu patient sur tout ça il
s'appelle Smoky c'est un slammeur qui
est au cœur du mouvement du balai
citoyen qui a renversé le régime
autoritaire de bless qu' pas auraéit et
que j'ai rencontré un jour parce que
quand ils avaient fait ce mouvement
citoyen qui a fait partir ce président,
ils avaient fait des révélations avec
des jeunes journalistes sur des fonds
européens qui étaient destinés à la
construction d'une autoroute et
l'autoroute n'était pas elle avait pas
les bas côté stables, elle avait pas les
lumières où il fallait alors les jeunes
allaient vite. Parfois il y avait des
accidents mortels. révélation. Une
partie de ces fonds européens ont été
piqués et ont servi, y compris, à des
villas, des palais pour le président.
Révélation libératrice. Ah bah c'est
bien la preuve quand même voilà que que
c'est un quand même. Il prend
les fonds européen et cetera, il
s'occupe pas du pays. Et là Smoky, il
est jeune hein mais il est sage hein
comme un grillot africain. Il dit "Voyez
monsieur Plenel, vous les journalistes,
votre rôle c'est de lever les lièvres
mais ensuite c'est à la société de les
attraper."
Mais la société calée dans le guidon,
mais elle attrape et regardez qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé là depuis 6 mois. Ils
comprennent les choses des gens, des
gens qui étaient isolés, travailleurs
pauvres, femmes isolées, retraité qui à
un moment disent "Ça va pas, je
m'engage, je vais sur un rond-point là
où ça va tout on s'arrête jamais."
C'est la fin qui les a motivé.
C'est c'est
la conscience. La conscience de
l'injustice, tout part de l'injustice
fiscale. C'est pas des gens qui disent
qu'ils veulent pas d'impôts. C'est pas
des gens qui sont contre des mesures
pour le climat. C'est des gens qui se
rendent compte qu'en fait les décisions
prises par ce pouvoir, c'est des
décisions où ceux qui devraient donner
plus donnent moins et ceux qui gagnent
moins donnent plus. Donc c'est
l'injustice et du coup c'est le moteur
de l'égalité et c'est et c'est c'est
comment dire c'est bien sûr que qu'on
peut se dire ça donne pas de réalité
politique tout de suite je ne sais pas
pour qui voter dimanche. Euh c'est des
mouvement d'ailleurs les gilets jaunes
est un mouvement de l'abstention parce
que l'événement véritable de 2017 c'est
pas le chamboulet uniquement en marche
et France insoumise les deux mouvements
he qui ont bousculé la donne.
L'événement premier, ça a été les
présidentielles où il y a eu le plus
fort taux d'abstention, la plus forte
moyenne sur neuf neuf au-dessus de la
moyenne par rapport au neuf élections
présidentielles précédentes. Donc la
montée du du rejet démocratique, non pas
d'un rejet des élections par
antidémocratisme, mais parce que c'est
une confiscation démocratique. La
démocratie c'est pas les élections.
C'est pas simplement choisir des
représentants
ses maîtres. C'est pas non seulement
choisir ses maîtres. Bien sûr, c'est
c'est une vieille formule, hein, la
tyrannie douce. C'est-à-dire qu'on
demande au peuple tous les tous les 5
ans de sortir de la servitude pour
choisir son maître et puis entre-temps,
on lui dit d'y revenir. Qu'est-ce que
nous disent les gilets jaunes ? Et c'est
ça qui attaque le pouvoir. Non, la
démocratie c'est le droit de se réunir,
de s'assembler. Et aujourd'hui, on
interdit par des décrets préfecturales
des réunions sur sur les ronds-points.
C'est le droit de manifester et on a
voulu le mettre en cause. C'est la
liberté de dire et on essaie de la
réprimer et puis c'est la liberté de
s'informer, c'est le droit de savoir et
on s'en prend à la presse. Ça c'est
comme les quatre pieds d'une table.
Quatre pieds d'une table. Alors, vous
pouvez poser le plateau sur les quatre
pieds, c'est le droit de vote. Ça, c'est
je je me prononce, je dis oui, je dis
non, je choisis les représentants. Mais
pour que la table tienne bien, il faut
ces quatre pieds et ils sont ils
précèdent, c'est des droits fondamentaux
et nous, on est au cœur de ça.
Là, on s'éloigne juste une petite minute
de du journalisme. La collapsologie, ça
vous parle ou pas ?
Alors, on a il y a des débats, il y a
une journaliste
et le Ouais. un média part qui on a
beaucoup traité hein et il y a une
journaliste qui aime pas trop le ceux
qui qui qui en font une sorte de
catastrophisme de l'effondrement hein
nous la présenter
Jad Lingard vous devriez elle est
formidable il y a eu une interview
d'elle dans reporteur c'est elle qui a
fait un petit livre s'appelle jeu crise
climatique elle est elle est c'est
vraiment une une des signatures à médiia
part sur l'enquête sur la prise de
conscience sur sur la crise climatique
bien avant hein qu'on que dès le début
de médiia part donc moi je en En fait,
je je pense que
et ça je crois qu'il faut le prendre
comme ça,
il faut c'est en ayant conscience de la
catastrophe
qu'on peut l'éviter. C'est-à-dire que
moi, je n'aime pas les théories du
déclin. On dit il est irréversible,
hein. Ça va dans cette direction. Le
futur est écrit. Pas plus qu'il est
écrit genre on va les lendemains qui
chantent. Le futur, il dépend de nous.
Il dépend de nous. Alors, il faut avoir
vieille formule optimiste de la volonté,
pessimiste de l'intelligence. La vérité,
c'est que la catastrophe, elle est déjà
là. La catastrophe, c'est que tout
continue comme avant. C'est ça la
catastrophe. Elle est pas devant nous.
La catastrophe, regardez la course de
vitesse sur euh le désordre climatique,
notre responsabilité. Vous savez, les
animaux, nous sommes 0,3 % du vivant et
j'inclus les humains dans ces animaux.
Les végétaux sont beaucoup plus
importants que nous et ils ont une
intelligence que nous n'avons pas. Il y
a pas de cœur, il y a pas de cerveau,
mais vous pouvez brouter de l'herbe,
elle continuera à vivre. Les végétaux
ont des choses à nous apprendre. Il y a
un botaniste Stefano Moncuso qui raconte
ça très bien. Donc, comment dire, il
faut nous remettre en cause dans notre
rubrice de puissance. Nous sommes une
espèce tellement intelligente qu'elle
oublie son lien au tout vivant du tout
monde sa relation. Elle l'oublie dans
ses pratiques de prédation, de
consommation, d'avidité, de propriété
matérielle. Mais elle l'oublie aussi
quand elle cède au racisme, quand elle
cède à la xénophobie, car elle oublie la
relation à elle-même, elle oublie la
relation à l'autre. Et donc nous voyons,
elle est là cette catastrophe. elle est
là quand vous avez euh le ministre des
affaires étrangères de Bolzonaro qui
Bolzonaro lui-même est raciste, est
homophobe et euh aligné sur Netaniaahu
en Israël euh et et est un un c'est un
homme qui qui pousse au pire hein qui
pousse au pire et que dit son ministre
affaire étrangère ? Le changement
climatique, c'est un complot marxiste.
Complot marxiste. Bon, quand vous voyez
Trump comme ça, donc la catastrophe,
elle est là et elle produit ces monstres
politiques. Ces monstres politiques que
nous voyons nêre. C'est une phrase de
Gramchi que j'avais popularisé. La
crise, c'est quand un vieux monde est en
train de mourir mais il s'accroche. Il
s'accroche à sa puissance et un nouveau
monde, on le voit, on le sent, vous en
êtes, tarde à naître. Mais la phrase
importante, c'est dans cet entre deux
suscite surgissent les phénomènes
morbides les plus variés. Ce qu'une
traduction littéraire a dit de manière
plus forte. Dans ce clair obscur
surgissent les monstres et on en voit
plein autour de nous. Donc la
catastrophe, elle est déjà là. Et donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ? Et c'est
pour ça que la concomitance gilets
jaunes et mobilisation des jeunes pour
le climat, fin du monde, fin du mois,
c'est pour nous le même combat, le mot
d'ordre qui a surgi le 8 décembre. le 8
décembre, journée la plus dure hein, la
plus violente, mais c'est là où a eu
lieu la première convergence est
essentielle parce que nous disent les
jeunes du climat ? Il disent à quoi ça
sert que j'aille tous les vendredis à
l'école là hein ? l'appel de Greta
Gunsberg, c'est dire "Attendez, un
moment vous les les adultes vous êtes
irresponsables, hein, faut changer le
logiciel et c'est pas du blab blabla,
faut vraiment le changer hein." Et et
c'est pour ça que je parlais tout à
l'heure de l'éparpillement des listes
progressistes,
émancipatrices, se revendiquant d'idéos
d'égalité et de démocratie, quel que
soit le bilan de ces forces politiques,
hein. Moi je je je dis juste là, il y a
une responsabilité hein de pas
comprendre qu'on est dans un moment où
il faut ce que ce que Jor avait fait.
Vous savez c'est les c'est ce que
j'appelle les vaincus victorieux. Jor
est assassiné en 14
quand arrive la guerre qu'il a tout fait
pour tenter d'éviter mais on sait que
c'est lui qui a gagné hein. C'est de lui
dont on se souviendra pas de son
assassin comme on se souvient de Rosa
Luxembourg et pas de ses assassins,
hein, qui elle m'a m tué en en 2019. Et
pourquoi en en 1919, pourquoi je vous
dis ça sur Jores, Jores,
qu'est-ce qu'il fait quand il a le
sentiment que ce monde qui ressemble au
nôtre un monde de révolution
industrielle formidable, l'électricité
va arriver la voiture Ford va arriver
l'avion, le télégraphe regarder les
immeubles à Paris, même l'immeuble où on
est, regardez les dates où ils sont
construites, c'est pendant cette époque
là, c'est l'expansion coloniale, il y a
beaucoup d'argent, beaucoup mais il y a
le même niveau, Thomas Piquetti l'a
montré, d'inégalité qu'aujourd'hui. un
tout petit monde qui capte hein, vous
connaissez les chiffres d'Oxfam, il y a
26 familles, 26 personnes dont deux
français, Bernard Arnaud et les
héritiers de Bétancour qui possède
autant que 3 milliards 700 millions
d'individus. Donc c'est intenable. C'est
intenable. Et qu'est-ce comment fait
cette société si c'est intenable ? Elle
va à la guerre. Elle va à la guerre. Et
Trump, il est en train d'y aller hein
avec l'Iran. Il il de toute façon, c'est
la continuité, hein. Ils ont commencé
avec l'Irak et cetera. Ils y vont, ils y
vont, ils y vont, ils y vont, ils vont à
la guerre parce qu'il y a en plus des
industries qui veulent se hein qui font
de l'argent derrière tout ça. Il y a des
lobbyes, il y a un lobby
militaro-industriel, il existe, il a
toujours existé. C'est pas nouveau, on
va à la guerre. Qu'est-ce qu'il fait Jor
conscience de ça ? Joris n'a jamais été
ministre, n'a jamais été président du
conseil et il y avait pas de président
au suffrage universel. Donc, il y avait
pas la folie du présidentialisme.
Qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? Il prend son
bâton de pèlerin et il va voir tout le
monde. Il va voir les socialistes
modérés, il va voir les socialistes
radicaux, il va voir les sectaires, il
va voir les les plus ouverts, il va voir
tout le monde. Il dit "Attendez, faut
arrêter de déconner, faut se
rassembler." Et ça fait 1905
le premier congrès des organisations
sociales françaises. Et à l'époque, ils
sont tous avec les futurs bolcheviques
et les futurs communistes, ils sont tous
dans la dans la dans la même
internationale. Et quand Jor est
assassiné, la gauche radicale de
l'époque, c'est-à-dire Trotky,
c'est-à-dire Luxembourg, lui rend
hommage. Lui rend hommage. C'estd ce
type, il était pas dans l'ubrisce
personnel, il était pas dans comment
c'est pour ma pomme, comment je suis le
leader et tout. Il dit comment je suis
l'unificateur ? Je l'unicouvateur
j'ouvre une parenthèse sur
l'unificateur.
En tant que média,
est-ce qu'on peut inviter tout le monde
?
Nous médi il y a un parti qu'on a décidé
de pas inviter, on le traite hein, on le
cite euh et du coup en rétorsion lui
envance nous a décidé de nous de nous
blacklister. C'est le Front National,
c'est l'extrême droite. Pourquoi ? Parce
que je veux dire là c'est ce sont des
adversaires de principe. Je ne considère
pas quels que soient mes désaccords avec
la politique d'Enmarche que tous les
militants d'Emarche sont aussi
caricaturaux que castan que voilà je les
interpelle si je les rencontre. Je dis
comment vous pouvez accepter ça vous qui
vous dites sur des principes libéraux et
progressistes quand même c'est
inadmissible c'est violences policières
et cetera donc donc enance l'extrême
droite est l'héritière d'une formation
politique et elle ne l'a jamais remis en
cause comme d'ailleurs Salvini en Italie
ce sont des gens qui n'ont pas remis en
cause leur héritage hein les communistes
ce sont des gens qui se sont expliqués
sur le stalinisme se sont expliqués sur
le goulag là eux ils ne se sont pas
expliqués vous le voyez par nos infos
chaque fois qu'on cherche la biographie
de jeunes cadres du Front National. On
trouve ici un salut nazi, là une photo
là et cetera. On trouve toutes sortes de
choses qui qui montrent une culture une
culture où il y a l'antisémitisme où il
y a
Est-ce que Est-ce que vous avez déjà
reçu Étienne Chouir ?
Étienne Chouir ? Oui, on ne l'a pas
reçu. On a on était pas d'accord à un
moment où il s'est égaré quand même. Il
s'est égaré sur Alain Soral très
clairement. Il y a des années.
Oui, il y a des années. Mais comment
dire quand il s'est égaré, on savait sur
Alain Soral, il sa Alors par ailleurs,
moi j'ai participé à des débats où
Étienne Schouir était là, y compris he
fait par la société des amis d'Henry
Guillemin. C'était un débat autour de
Robespierre, autour de la Révolution
française. Donc moi, je discute. Voilà,
comment dire ? Je vais vous dire et ça
c'est aussi pour les internautes qui
nous écoutent parce que chacun fait
maintenant son savoir et va avoir et
tout. Et moi, je voudrais mettre en
garde gentiment, hein. Voilà, moi tel
que vous me voyez,
ma notoriété, elle est liée à un travail
collectif.
Moi, je rencontre devant un collectif.
J'ai toujours fait ça, parfois ça m'a
joué des tours, mais j'ai toujours
travaillé dans un univers collectif.
J'ai toujours été syndiqué. J'ai
toujours considéré que voilà, j'avais je
faisais avec d'autres. Je pas je me suis
en clair. J'ai des idées
bonnes ou mauvaises mais j'ai des idées.
Je fais mon métier, mon travail. J'ai
parfois des intuitions comme ce qu'on a
fait avec Media Partide
avec un collectif. Je les construis avec
un collectif. En clair, je me méfie dans
notre époque des gens qui ne
s'autorisent que d'eux-mêmes.
Je me méfie de ça, du raccourci, hein,
parce que à un moment, et je m'en suis
souvent dans mon métier, j'ai vu des
gens qui étaient des bons enquêteurs qui
à un moment la notoriété, on devient
vedette, hein, et du coup, on fait ses
livres et on ne s'autorise plus que de
soi-même et parfois on fait des bêtises
parce que votre premier collègue, votre
premier contrôleur, c'est votre
collègue. Moi en clair, je crois au
collectif donc je dis ça sur bon des
person quand quand vous exprimez sur une
chaîne une chaîne katari vous en rendez
compte suis jamais exprimé sur une
chaîne Qatarie.
Ah je voulais dire Algzira English
peut-être Alzira English quand ils sont
venus m'interviewer sur pour les
musulmans. C'est une émission d'un
journaliste qui est à Londres. C'est ça
hein ?
Aljazira.
Oui c'est Alzira. C'est un journaliste
palestinien qui a une émission spéciale
de débat et il est venu de Londres me
faire parler du livre que j'avais fait
mais je ne fais pas d'interview
sur une chaîne Qatarie au sens je
réponds à des questions sur ce livre que
j'avais fait en 2014 he qui est un livre
important. Voilà.
Autre question
Alzira vous savez il y a AG plus c'est
très compliqué Algzira. Algézira vous
avez vous avez beaucoup de jeunes
français maintenant qui travaillent dans
cette chaîne vous le savez.
Oui.
Alors nous nous Medéiapartment
tout ce qui est des chaînes qui relè en
clair la propagande d'un état
comme France 24
comme Russia tout plutôt d'abord
France 24 c'est la même chose.
Non France 24 il y a plus d'autonomie
des journalistes si vous regardez bien.
Non non je pense
ils utilisent pas de botes France 24 sur
internet. Je sais pas ça vous direz
peut-être je sais pas mais en tout cas
je parle sur le travail journalistique
hein c'est comme RFI c'est comme c'est
issu du travail Russia Touda encore une
fois je rappelle que l'opposition
politique en Russie aujourd'hui n'a pas
beaucoup de place je rappelle que quand
même les journalistes sont réprimés je
rappelle qu'une conseur d'investigation
a été assassinée
en France il y a pas encore d'assassinat
de journalist
ou oui mais je rappelle je dis ça par
rapport à cette idée il y a une liberté
attention hein c'est comme
Free
F Europe quand la CIA avait ses chaînes.
Attention hein à cette illusion là,
c'est la liberté. Je suis désolé hein
quand je sors le financement russe du
Front National
hein, c'est pas sur Russia Todday.
C'est pas sur Russia Today.
Non, c'est pas sur Russia Todday hein.
C'est pas sur Russia Todday. Quand on
sort ça, quand je raconte que l'affaire
Benala, il y a cette histoire avec un
oligarque proche de Poutine, cet aspect
de l'affaire Benala, il est pas sur
Russia tout.
Bon voilà, donc je dis ça sur parce que
je pense que sur Alzira dire résumé à
une chaîne Qatari est un peu sommaire.
C'est Alzira, bon le Qatar tout petit.
Le Qatar, comme vous le savez, n'est pas
aligné sur la position américaine
jusqu'au bouthiste via les via l'Arabie
Saoudite et via les Émirat, hein.
D'ailleurs, c'est pour ça qu'il y a
cette tension parce que eux refusent la
course à la guerre et Alzira est par
rapport à à d'autres chaînes en arabe,
une chaîne évidemment qui ne sort pas de
scoop sur ce qui se passe au Qatar sans
aucun doute mais qui est beaucoup plus
pluraliste hein dans son dans son dans
son contenu. et Algészira English est de
très grande qualité en clair. Voilà.
Une question, ça là c'est une question
un peu plus personnelle pour notre
chaîne. On n'arrive pas à voir le quai
d'Or et son porte-parole.
Alors on comprend pas pourquoi.
Bah ça il faut leur demander.
Mais alors on leur a demandé alors on
parce que parce qu' parce que parce que
quoi ? Parce que
parce que bon je peux parler
vulgairement.
Oui
oui. Bon ils nous font une petite
descente d'organe à chaque fois qu'on
essaie de les approcher, hein.
Ils ont un peu peur de venir s'exprimer
en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner des conseils pour aller les
attraper ? Est-ce qu'on les prend à
l'arrache avec une caméra ? Pourquoi ça
c'est si important d'avoir le
porte-parole d'un ministère ?
Non, pas le porte-parole, on préférait
avoir le ministre.
Bon, voilà. Bon euh le qu d'ors c'est
important pour vous ?
Moi, vous savez, c'est la société. J'ai
fait un article là dimanche dernier qui
s'appelle Foura.
Faire faire le pari de la société contre
la politique du pire. C'est la société.
C'est là qu'il y a les idées. C'est là
qu'il y a les idées. Les lives les plus
réussis puisque c'est un live qu'on fait
en ensemble ce soir. Les lives les plus
réussis de Méiabart qui ont le plus plus
buzé. Je parle pas des campagnes
électorales qui ont le plus buzé, c'est
quand on fait venir des activistes le
live sur la sécurité, le live sur le
climat, le live sur les discriminations
et cetera. Quand on fait venir la
société, c'est là que ça se passe. C'est
l'intelligence collective, elle est là.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview
parce que vous avez quelque chose de
prévu juste après. Et la prochaine fois
que vous venez, il faudra nous accorder
plus de temps que ça la prochaine fois.
Attention
donc je vais vous envoyer trois petites
questions d'internet et on va finir sur
la dernière question qu'on pose à tout
le monde qui est laissée qui n'est pas
une question qui est laissé un conseil
pour les jeunes générations. Alors je
les prends à la volée. Que pensez-vous
du dîner du siècle ?
Vous pensez qu'il faut que j'en pense
quelque chose ? Ouais, c'est la question
d'internet, hein.
Oui. Oui. Bah, j'en pense que c'est
exactement tout cet entre soi que nous
avons critiqué depuis le début de cet
entretien.
Autre question internet. Que pensez-vous
du Conseil de l'ordre des journalistes à
l'image des médecins et des avocats ?
Je suis contre.
Ah, je suis contre.
Ouais. Je vais avoir le même conseil de
l'ordre. Le conseil de l'ordre,
excusez-moi, hein, c'est une création de
pétin je vous rappelle juste hein au
passage hein sur sur l'ordre des
médecins. Mais quoi ? Je vais discuter
des scoupes de médiat euh avec
Bernard Arnaud, avec
les propriétaires de la presse qui n'est
pas indépendante économiquement. Voilà.
Moi, j'ai j'ai on a un code de
déontologie,
on a des lecteurs qui sont nos premiers
juges qui peuvent nous abandonner, qui
peuvent nous quitter, qui peuvent nous
critiquer. On n'est pas au-dessus des
lois. J'ai parlé de la loi de 1880 et
puis j'aime pas cette idée l'ordre. Vous
savez, nous on est un ferment de
désordre. Le désordre est créateur. Vous
savez comment la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme appelle le journaliste
pour défendre le droit du journaliste ?
Elle dit watch dog. En anglais, ça veut
dire le chien qui regarde. En français,
ça dit quoi ? Chien de garde. C'est pas
beau chien de garde, hein. C'est pas ça
peut.
Oui, mais mais c'est pas expression
chien de garde. Ça veut dire quoi ? Ça
veut dire que oui, un journaliste, si on
prend l'image du chien de garde, il peut
être
Et les nouveaux chiens de garde, ils
sont toujours Non, ça c'est ça, ils sont
toujours existés parce que ça reprenait
le titre d'un livre de Paul Nisan. Tout
ça n'est encore une fois n'est pas
nouveau, hein. Il faut toujours se
battre contre une forme d'ordre établi,
de conservatisme. Faut toujours avancer.
L'émancipation, c'est le mouvement,
c'est le déplacement. Mais je continue
juste sur quand même sur les chiens de
garde. Chienî de garde, ils peuvent
avoir de la bave à la gueule, montrer
des crot, aboyer à pasur, pas être
sympathique, mais il vaut mieux ce
désordre que le l'ordre du silence.
Euh euh que pensez-vous d'Acrimède ?
Akrimè, la critique des médias, c'est
très utile et le travail d'Acrimè est
très utile, même si parfois je les ai
trouvé dans le passé un peu injustes sur
euh ce que nous avons pu faire, mais
après tout la critique a le droit d'être
injuste. Parce que j'ai un reproche à
faire à Akrimèd, c'est qu'ils ne sont
pas participatifs. C'est-à-dire que
quand ils font une critique des médias,
on peut pas répondre sur le site
d'Acrimed. On peut pas on on n'est pas
dans une relation participative. Donc il
donnent leur jugement et parfois il est
très bien nourri, très bien explicite
mais on ne peut pas le discuter. Et je
dis ça parce que pour moi c'est très
important aujourd'hui cette remise en
cause y compris pour des avant-gardes
politiques. Se dire on suis au-dessus
là, je suis un sachant mais pour le pour
l'émancipation contre les oligarques,
feu sur le quartier général mais je suis
quand même au-dessus de vous parce que
je sais mieux que vous ce qui est bon
pour vous. Nous on n pas fait ça.
Non mais on peut les critiquer, ils sont
c'est facile de les appeler.
Non mais on peut attend bien sûr. Non
mais je parle sur le côté participatif
parce que c'est très bien leur travail
mais ça pourrait
beaucoup de ressources. Ils sont
peut-être pas bons en informatique
réinform. Non mais si si je les connais
hein, je connais même les fondateurs. Je
connais je connais Henry Maler bien sûr
mais Henry Maller, j'ai milité avec lui
dans ma jeunesse. Donc vous savez tout
ça ce sont des des vieux vieux vieux
combats.
Question d'internet comment vous
organisez-vous pour penser contre
vous-même
par le travail collectif. C'est une
collectivité hein. C'est une
collectivité. Donc on pense contre
nous-même. On pense on n'est pas
uniforme. Il y a pas un patron avec des
consignes verticales. Il y a des
contrepouvoirs à Médiapart.
Je peux je peux vous poser une question
plus personnelle ?
Allez, allez-y.
Euh euh votre femme, elle a les mêmes
idées que vous.
On s'est connu quand on était militant
dans notre jeunesse. Donc ça fait ça
fait évidemment des valeurs partagées
hein quand on était dans dans ceux qui
défendaient la vérité contre certains
mensonges d'une partie de la gauche à
l'époque. Pour le reste, elle est pas du
tout Oui, je parle du stalinisme. On a
beaucoup menti. On a beaucoup menti
au 20e siècle en disant "Bon, pas c'est
pas grave, on fait pas d'omelette sans
casser d'eux." Puis après, il y a eu un
grand chagrin, hein. Euh, autrement, il
y a une une différence et une force,
c'est qu'elle elle n'est pas du tout
dans nos métiers, hein. Elle est dans
une autre temporalité. Elle est
chercheuse au CNRS. Voilà. Donc, on est
dans d'autres univers
parfois on n'est pas d'accord, parfois
on discute, parfois dans la famille.
Si si elle travaillait par exemple à
valeur actuelle. Mais moi d'abord, je
crois que ne me serait jamais arrivé de
vivre avec un journaliste. Je ne
fréquente pas les journalistes. Je
travaille avec des journalistes. Je suis
dans ce métier et dans cette profession,
mais ma vie
n'est pas redondante avec ce
Est-ce que vous regrettez d'avoir reçu
Macron à la campagne présidentielle ?
Non, parce que je pense que y compris je
regrette pas parce que trois fois
puisque n'oubliez pas le 15 avril l'an
dernier avec Jean-Jacques Bourdin hein
quand on avait dit à la revoyure un an
après et qu'ils ont proposé que ça se
passe de cette figure là et quand vous
revoyez cette interview du 15 avril hein
c'est 15 jours avant on le sait pas mais
les événements de Benala puisqueaprès
ils vont les étouffer vous voyez la
crispation vous voyez le contraste
revoir l'interview du 5 mai 2017 et
l'interview où on joue les mauvais
garnement l'appelant pas monsieur le
président disant votre mouvement c'est
pas en marche c'est en force en lui
parlant tout de suite de l'évasion
fiscale et cetera hein et vous faites
vous regardez ces deux entretiens ben
vous voyez le chemin parcouru donc nous
comment comment on fait dans ces cas-là
un entretien c'est pas il s'agit pas
d'un débat nous on n'est pas là pour
avoir le dernier mot on est là pour
faire surgir une réalité et essayer de
montrer cette réalité qu'est-ce qu'il y
a dans le ventre dans la campagne
présidentielle on montre qu'en effet il
y a quelque chose chose. Le bonhomme
n'est pas qu'un artifice hein, il a du
répondant hein, il tient bon. Et à
l'époque, il tient un discours où il
tient les debout la vision libérale,
économique et sociale. Mais la vision,
c'est sa formule, une révolution
démocratique profonde. N'oubliez pas, il
emploie cette formule. On a retrouvé
récemment ce qu'il a déclaré sur les
violences policières en 2017. Vous avez
vu, c'était formidable. Qui ne pouvait
c'est ça lui est opposable mot à mot.
Donc nous, on a fait surgir cette
ambiguïté, cette tension du macronisme.
Mais nous l'indépendance, c'est à la
minute même où il est élu. Et du coup,
qu'est-ce qu'on a montré ? On a montré
que tout ça tout ça s'est déséquilibré
tout de suite. Et du coup, on l'a quand
on fait l'interview le 15 avril hein, on
le met en évidence. Et là, j'ai vu
quelqu'un totalement renfermé et la
suite de ce point de vue ne m'étonne
pas. Il est dans sa bulle, il est passé
comme t tous ses présidents. Le
présidentialisme est plus fort queux. et
il révèle un peu comme vous savez ce
portrait de Dorian Grey hein, c'est un
roman et un film hein, il y a un
portrait qui se décompose et qui montre
toute laideur cachée d'un type qui se
croit éternel et jeune et beau. Et là on
a vu ça avec Sarkozi, ça a révélé son
hystérie. Avec Hollande, ça a révélé son
impuissance. Et avec Macron, ça révèle
son égotisme, son narcissisme, hein, son
repli personnel. Il est habité par
lui-même. Alors, c'est une performance.
Il fait 7h 8h. Il serait venu ici, lui,
il aurait fait 7 8h, hein. Bon, mais
c'est la person qui tiendrait plus de 20
minutes avec moi en fait.
Bon, bon, d'accord. D'accord. Non, mais
vous savez, vous savez, il est il est
assez faux de lui-même pour avoir du
plaisir à ça. C'est pour ça que je vous
disais, attention aux gens qui ne
s'autorisent que d'eux-même. C'est quoi
une vie démocratique à tout niveau, dans
une ville, dans une entreprise, dans une
société, c'est des balances de pouvoir,
de contrôle. les uns les autres. Et ça
encore une fois, j'y insiste parce que
il suffit pas de se dire feu sur le
quartier général pour résoudre ce
problème hein. Ce problème est devant
nous. L'invention démocratique, elle est
devant nous. Le donc avant-dernière
question, si j'arrive à récupérer mon
écran impeccable. Pourquoi avoir
qualifié l'enquête de Denis Robert sur
Clearstream d'enquête Canada Dry ?
J'ai jamais employé cette formule.
J'ai jamais employé cette formule. J'ai
eu des désaccords professionnels avec
Denis Robert. Je l'ai défendu devant la
justice. Comment dire ? Je je défends
une certaine façon de faire ce travail
et en effet dans un cadre collectif par
ailleurs, je lui souhaite bonne chance
maintenant qu' qu'il a pris la
responsabilité d'un média collectif qui
est le média. Vous savez qu'après
l'ultime crise du média qui en a connu
beaucoup en un an, c'est Denis Robert
qui maintenant succède à Ha Lancelin
après Sopia Chikirou et après
les les autres fondateurs.
Donc quelles sont vos relations avec Ran
Branco ? Pourquoi cette réaction
disproportionnée envers Juan Branc alors
que les révélations n'avaient rien de
dangereux pour Media Part ? Nous, on a
sincèrement faut lui poser la question
hein. Faut lui poser la question. Il a
raconté des choses inexactes sur Niel
dans le capital et par ailleurs, on a
fait une critique de son livre. Voilà.
Voilà, on fait une critique, c'est le
débat, il pas d'accord. Je vous rappelle
juste hein, journal participatif sur
Mediapart, Rand Branco, a son blog et il
répond. Et il répond à qui ? y compris à
des gens qui l'ont soutenu qui
maintenant le critiquent, y compris à
des gens qui se réclament de la même
radicalité politique que lui mais qui
sont pas d'accord avec lui.
Vous avez lu son livre,
vous avez lu son livre ?
Moi non, j'ai pas eu le temps pour
l'instant. D'autres Joseph Confavreux
l'a lu hein. J'ai lu la casse de Laurent
Maudui qui est formidable et et où il y
a toutes ces informations étaient là.
Euh je connais Ran Branco, je l'ai suivi
quand il a travaillé dans les ministères
socialistes, puis après avec Julien
Assange, puis ensuite avec la France
insoumise et maintenant comme ça. C'est
des itinéraires personnels et grand bien
lui fasse. Il y a pas besoin, il y a pas
besoin pour ça de tirer partout comme
ça, d'être trop fou de soi-même. Trop
fou de soi-même. J'ai trop vu de gens se
fracasser pour ça. Voilà. Et donc je
redis juste ne faisons pas de fausses
polémiques. Nous on fait ce qu'on fait.
Vous en êtes juge par ailleurs, je vous
dis Brand Branco, il lit Méiapart, il se
nourrit de Médiapart et il s'en nourrit
tellement qu'il blogue sur Méia Part et
il est le bienvenu toujours.
Eddou Plenel, laissez un conseil pour
les jeunes générations, une bouteille à
la mer, quelque chose d'impérissable sur
les réseaux.
Non, impérissable. Agis en ton lieu et
pense avec le monde. Agis en ton lieu et
pense avec le monde. C'est un talisman
pour moi. C'est une phrase de quelqu'un
que j'appelais double maître parce qu'il
faisait deux maîtres. Mai tr qui est
Édouard Glissant, un grand poète,
philosophe et engagé de mon pays
d'enfance, la Martinique. Agis en ton
lieu et pense avec le monde. Agis là où
tu es. Agis dans ton entreprise. Agis
dans ta rue. Agis dans ta ville. Agis là
où tu vis. Hein ? Ne regarde pas. Voilà.
Ne regarde pas que tu tu es en haut
ailleurs. D'abord tu es requis là où tu
es. Mais pense avec le monde parce que
tu vis avec le monde et le monde c'est
le tout vivant et le tout monde comme
disait Édouard Glisson. Et puis par
ailleurs, ce que je voulais vous dire
puisque on est à veille d'élection et et
que il y a il y a cette interview qui
était diffusé, on a décidé à partir de
minuit pendant 2 jours, tous ceux qui
ont écouté pour qu'il jugent sur pièce,
Médiapart est en accès libre samedi et
dimanche toute la journée. Il y a pas
besoin de s'abonner pour lire Médiapart
et à cette occasion il y a une offre
spéciale d'abonnement 6 mois 20 €. Donc
si ça vous plaît, profitez-en, soutenez
la presse libre et indépendante. Seuls
nos lecteurs peuvent nous acheter.
Et ben, Edouille Penel, merci d'être
venu nous voir euh euh sur ce média qui
est aussi un média libre et indépendant.
C'est on dit coupé maintenant.
Et ouais,
coupé.
[Musique]